so how are you guys doing today pretty
good I love the movie you guys were
amazing so first off I gotta say you
usually have a stand-up comedy
background how was it bringing that your
comedy and your improvisation into this
movie it was so fun it's so dope because
I feel like you know a lot of people
want you to just like show up and say
the words and it's so nice when you can
like blend both worlds and just see what
happens when you just say it the way you
would say it and obviously like this
character has a lot of thoughts and like
what happens when you know you just let
a comedian go and what I love about you
know this movie written by two hilarious
comedic actors is that they understand
to lean into that and that only makes
the story pop so it was dope and and for
you Daniel usually like before your
movies are coming out you're doing you
show us some behind the scenes some
martial arts training all that well how
is it going into this and kind of being
the love interest in and taking a Cyro
instead of like being like all action II
but you're like more of the love
interest instead it was a lot of fun but
you didn't see my behind the scenes
martial arts for this movie what working
on it yeah I was the base of the pyramid
it was a lot yeah we had a chicken fight
he was on top of my shoulders you know
no we're joking it was a lot of fun it's
you know it's you don't want to keep
doing the same thing you know throughout
it throughout your career it's nice to
be able to mix it up and these were the
right people to mix it up with yeah yeah
and I like comedy and I'm just trying to
be like you guys so it was it was the
right environment in the right place to
start so I'm super thrilled to be a part
of it oh man and Michelle you recently
just launched a podcast called adulting
did you give me some or could you give
other general advice for somebody who
was afraid to tell their crush how they
feel like what would you tell them how
would you tell them to approach that oh
man you know why just take a shot and
just a shot of alcohol let's take a shot
at love you know I with no what is it no
risk there's no reward like whiskey
what is the worst that could happen dude
I mean you're gonna be alone you're
gonna be alone anyways if you don't say
anything
so yeah set it up set it up I want to
hear this podcast adult adult Hank I
would love to have you do it I'll do it
yeah perfect my friend Jordan Carlos and
I just sit down and talk to people about
what we think adult thing is a lot of
it's like finding your inner child -
it's like weird but also pay your taxes
on time that's very adult the IRS I'm
still learning for it I'm still learning
how to learn fast yes mhm and so can we
can we play a quick game real quick of
would you rather yes so would you rather
have your childhood crush admit their
feelings way too late or just never
reveal them at all the person that I
have a crush on no the court will the
person who was crushing on you um tell
me okay I might not be able to do
anything about it but I want to know
yeah let me know late better late than
never
all right would you rather screw up and
take yourself multiple times or have
somebody else grew up your best take
like it Oh what oh my goodness I say
screw it I want to screw up my own take
oh you can't alright alright what about
you Daniel a much more forgiving of
other people than I am of myself so I'd
rather have them screw up my take all
right oh no I would like unsubscribe I'm
like you're cancelled because if I
screwed up their best take I'll feel so
bad when to though yeah do it again
would you rather be asked to cry on cue
or sneeze on cue I'm just mixing it up
oh okay
crying is very easy for me I have four
month old twins so yeah I usually like
and in close with crying and your hand
and close hmm would you rather write
original would you rather do an original
material or write work with something
that's been adapted like a screenplay or
something like that well I'm in the
reboot of First Wives Club so let's just
say I'm down with a DAP tation mm-hmm
I'll do whatever's better you know I got
no pride of ownership
all right last one for you either work
with the director that gets too many
notes or director that doesn't give
enough
I'd rather more notes than not cuz I'm
not a mind-reader I can't you know I
can't figure out I've had both yeah
neither I good yes uh I guess more more
than none is better yeah there is a
thing as like a like over directing
somebody and it's like you could comment
down and let me figure it out for two
point two seconds but ninotchka Kahn the
director of this movie did not do it at
hunting mm-hmm she great she's great
she's great do you guys have any I know
you y'all were joking about the behind
scenes moment but do you have any
favorable moments from all onset that
you couldn't vividly remember like at
one time I did trip over like something
on the floor I like I did my line I
turned around I tripped I fell and I cut
my toe and I had the pregnancy belly on
and I just bounced right back up it was
like boy yeah but then like I cut my
tail and I saw there was blood
everywhere people were throwing paper
towels at me like they were Trump and
Puerto Rico I mean I said behind I see
it story
Collider perfect what it's a it's a
media website we cover the latest movie
news thank you trying I'm trying out and
then you have one more question for you
because we was recently announced that
you're joining the cast of stowaway oh
can you talk about what excited you
about the script or that you wanted to
join it yeah it's a it's a story of
three astronauts who are on a mission to
Mars and I play one of the astronauts
the other two are Anna Kendrick and Toni
Collette and the director as a fellow by
the name of Joe Penna who wrote and
wrote this movie called Arctic with Mads
Mikkelsen that I just saw it and it's a
really good very smart really tight
script and because the entire movie has
only four characters everyone has
something really interesting going on
throughout the entire storyline oh I'm
excited alright but no this is seriously
the last question it's gonna be probably
the toughest question pineapples on
pizza how do you guys feel about that
I say get that out of my face I don't
need that much heartburn and moisture on
pizza I don't know how I feel about that
because on one hand I don't prefer it
but on the other hand it's called the
Hawaiian pizza and I love the idea that
there's a pizza named after Hawaii so
some spam on it that's right that would
be that would be part of a Hawaii pizza
yeah Bob the camera guy loves that idea
yeah he's excited
all right wearing the shirt exactly I
just want to say thank you again for
talking with us I love the movie I can't
wait for more people to see this